the story of Henry Ford 7 1947 spring storms last
the midwest turning the River Rouge into a flood
that swept over the grounds of the Henry Ford
estate the old man now 84 went out to inspect
the damage the effort was too much he returned
to the mansion and a few hours later it was like
a mighty tree had fallen his passing marked the
end of an era he was born into the horse and wagon
age of the last century but the slow motion
of the times was not for him he sped up the
tempo for America unauthorized wheels the crude
cars developed swiftly into luxury autos more
than any other man Henry Ford was responsible
for the modern vehicles that have changed the
face and habits of America he gave Americans a
credo of success one that had served him well
in an early radio broadcast with Thomas Edison
he said make them smile do what the ideas were
like merchants he must study and work he must go
back in any arts as far as you can to figure out
the very beginning and it was the morning goes
back the further yeah yes Henry you preached and
practiced the virtue of hard work but ironically
your hatred of farm labour was the cause of your
success born on a farm during the Civil War you
went to a country school didn't get much of an
education you were 24 years old when you and your
wife moved to Detroit in 1893 the year your son
Edsel was born to experimented with a newfangled
contraption a horseless carriage a queer looking
thing you gave it a queer name the quadricycle
folks laughed at the notion but you carried on
encouraged by your wife late one night you pushed
it out of the shed you chose the late hour because
you didn't want the neighbors to laugh at you
if it didn't work but go it did that moment was
worth the years when you'd begged borrowed
and went hungry to raise the money to build
the quadricycle it worked and you were in business
the automobile business to advertise your gasoline
buggies you designed and built a racing car the
famous 999 you hired a speed crazy bicycle racer
named Barney Oldfield to drive it you took the
monster to a nearby racetrack Oldfield had never
driven a car before he hits 60 miles an hour a
week later the Ford Motor Company was organized
the first cars were expensive for those days only
the rich could afford them Henry wanted to bring
the price down but how the answer by speeding up
production but again how Henry found a solution
the assembly line the first assembly line was
crude little by little he improved it for Ford
a man who believed in machines it was a natural
step to harness power to the assembly line as the
new method was perfected the pace of automobile
production zoomed up and the price of cars zoomed
down in nineteen three eight hundred and fifty
dollars in 1914 five hundred and fifty dollars
you saw them everywhere the good old model T known
affectionately as that tin Lizzie you crank her up
jumped into the front seat and off you went with
a family Henry had added some new words to the
dictionary Sunday driver speed demon motorcycle
cop Henry had come a long way since the days of
the Little Shop behind the house he now owned
huge factories and foundries he was rich beyond
his wildest early dreams walking through a plant
one day he saw a worker glaring at the man hated
him but why was it because he had so much and
a man so little Henry resolved to change that
a few days later he issued an announcement it
shook industry to its roots business leaders
predicted that Henry would shortly go bankrupt
but he knew what he was doing he had a new idea
a big idea he figured that a well-paid worker
would be happier and more productive he reasoned
that a man with money in his pocket would buy
an automobile it sounded like insane logic in
1914 but Henry was right the cars sold faster five
hundred thousand cars sold in 1915 seven hundred
thousand in 1918 then a million and a quarter in
1920 but suddenly prosperity ended for the crash
business recession of 1921 yet Henri hard
yet always avoided dealing with Wall Street
now Wall Street bankers offered him a badly
needed alone if he would make one of their
men treasurer of the Motor Company Henry called
a meeting of his executives should he accept a
loan and turn control of the company over to
the money men it was the hardest decision of
Henry's life a crucial meeting to decide the
future of the Ford Motor Company Henry turned
down the Wall Street loan instead by economy
measures he reduced the price of his cars
result the assembly lines began to move again
by 1928 when the last Model T came off the line
Henry had built and sold 15 million of them a
year later you were called to the White House
the stock market crash had turned the country
into panic asked by President Hoover to help
restore public confidence you responded with
a general wage increase at a time when wages
were being slashed you were 61 years old one of
the wealthiest men in the world but your most
precious possessions were your grandchildren
your tastes were simple tinkering with an old
steam engine was fun you love to ice skate on a
frozen pond and dance the well-remembered country
dances of your youth or relaxation from business
you went on camping trips with Tom Edison and
John Burroughs you were with President Hoover in
Edison's laboratory on his 83rd birthday another
old friend was Orville Wright inventor of the
airplane but your most constant companion was
your son Edsel together you and Edsel campaigned
with Alf Landen the Republican presidential
candidate in 1936 you're proud of your cars
together you examine the new car models in
1939 those cars were displayed at the World's
Fair later that year at the fair you and Edsel
entertained Al Smith and fear Allah LaGuardia
those were their good days then came the Second
World War and you shifted to war production and so
drove the first Scout car to come out of the plant
at Willow Run near Detroit you built a huge new
plant for the production of bombers you and Edsel
checked the first planes to come off the new
assembly lines Edsel was your right hand more
and more you depended on him so when the blow
fell in 1943 the effect on you was devastating
80 years old you had outlived your son you
grieved with your grandson henry ii for his
father in all your eventful life you had
never suffered a blow half so severe grief
stricken you and your wife brought Edsel to
his last resting place Edsel gone it's hard
to believe seems impossible why you can recall
his face as it was only yesterday Edsel gone
who will take his place not Henry second Edsel
is oldest son he's in military service Benson
also in military service no one to take Edsel
place but yourself eighty years old now Henry
resumed the post of president of the company
the position Edsel had held for years back
into harness in old age Henry supervised
production of bombers when army officials
came the old man was there to show them around
it was a heavy load and fourscore years had
taken their toll of his strength Henry was
weary on his 83rd birthday a moment that
gladdened the old man a visit with children of
the neighborhood yet always loved children but
now they reminded him of the past later that
day a visit to the place where it all began
the quadricycle an old friend just about
the only survivor of the old days sitting
there in the machine henry's thoughts
drifted back to that fateful year 1893
himself as a young man the machine that was
to revolutionize travel and make his fortune
well both ambitions had been achieved few
men had lived a fuller life a year after
that visit with a quadricycle Henry Ford was
dead gone what forever present in the cars
he helped to create his memorial the concrete
highways speeding the country on its way he'd
built Scout cars and bombers to defend the
United States without him the face of the
land would not be the same of Henry Ford it
may well be said he left his mark on America